on est arrivé limité à l'aéroport qui
nous ont dit ok on prend vos téléphones
dans 2hures et vous les récupérez que à
votre tour et ben là j'ai mis YouTube et
j'ai mis ok comment faire du feu comment
tresser des feuilles de palmiers comment
faire des nœuds et en réalité salut
bienvenue dans ce nouvel interview à la
table aujourd'hui on va recevoir Fred
pour savoir ce qu'il a pensé et ce qu'il
a ressenti quand il a gagné colanta et
puis d'abord c'est quoi ce jeu colanta
comment on le vit de l'intérieur comment
on vit aussi le fait de trahir pour le
jeu les personnes avec qui on avait
monté des coalitions j'ai envie de tout
savoir merci à lui d'être là tu as gagné
colanta félicitations merci beaucoup et
et je pense que tu vas faire un peu
rager tout le monde c'estàdire c'est la
première fois que tu postulais si je dis
pas de bêtises es pris direct et tu as
gagné direct ouais tuas il a il y a eu
un parcours aussi idéal que le tien ou
pas euh je dois avouer que je me suis
pas renseigner plus que ça mais mais au
vu des différents candidats on voit
quand même qu'il y en a qui ont qui ont
insisté pour arriver ouais c'est ça
jusque là B il y a éine de ma saison qui
a fait 20 candidatures donc sur 20 ans
ça faisit 20 ans postulé euh il y a du
14 du 13 du 6 du 7 on est quelquesuns
quand même à à avoir fait en une fois et
bah c'est plutôt plaisant à postériori
tu en penses quoi tu te dis c'est le
destin c'est un coup de bol c'est en
fait je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
chance euh je pense je sais pas vraiment
comment fonctionne la production
j'imagine les planètes sont aligné si ça
se trouve tu te serais inscrit un jour
plus tôt peut-être que ta candidature
était pas vue au même moment tout à fait
tout à fait indépendamment du dossier où
il arrive ou au niveau de la pile et
puis après on voit qu'il a qu'il a quand
même bah des personnalités complètement
différentes donc je pense que
voilà la production doit peut-être
définir certains certains comment dire
très de caractère qui veulent le
retrouver et puis peut-être que je
faisais pile partie de de quelque chose
qui recherchait donc don beaucoup de
chance peut-être c'est c'est c'est une
aventure je pense que toi tu es bien
placé pour savoir à quel point c'est un
jeu qui rigole pas entre guillemets mais
oui il faut pas oublier que pour eux
c'est aussi un
divertissement effectivement s'il
prenait 10 fois ou 15 fois ton même
profil il se passerait pas grandchose
d'intéressant dans l'émission tu as
raison là-dessus ou c'est ça pourquoi tu
as postulé cette année-là plutôt qu'une
autre année alors faut savoir que
j'étais extrêmement bigleux ok j'étais
vraiment miop j'étais à moins 8 c'està
dire que d'ici je ne te je ne te verrai
même pas j'ai une boule de
chair impossible de distinguer quoi que
ce soit et puis donc je me suis opéré
des yeux puis je l'avais pas fait pour
le pour le jeu ou quoi que ce soit
c'était vraiment pour moi parce que mon
rêve dans la vie c'était vraiment de me
réveiller de voir parce que je suis
vraiment mie depuis tout petit donc j'ai
même pas le souvenir d'avoir été enfant
sans lunettes sans lunettes j'ai donc
fait l'opération et en fin de compte je
regardais l'émission je crois que cé en
2021 et donc à la fin de l'émission
cette année-là il y avait l'ouverture
des candidatures et là ma femme me dit
mais qu'est-ce que tuattends pour
postuler parce que tu avais déjà parlé
enfin tu regardais l'émission et tuavais
déjà dit que ça t'intéressao parce que
ça fait ouais ça fait quelques années
que je la regardais pas de manière hyper
assidu comme beaucoup ont pu l'être
ouais mais voilà je la connais depuis
tout petit j'ai vu les premiers avec
avec mon papa et en fait j'ai je me suis
toujours dit que c'était quelque chose
que je pourrais faire ouais dans T les
as un truc que tu pouvais faire c'était
ça qu voilà c'est c'est quelque chose
qui en fait ça me correspondait l'aspect
aventurier l'aspect social l'aspect
sportif je me disais juste c'est un truc
très cool que j'aimerais potentiellement
faire mais c'était pas non plus un rêve
ou quoi que ce soit mais donc quand je
me suis fait opérer et que ma femme m'a
dit mais mais vas-y en fait tu as plus
de parce qu'elle savait quand même qu'il
y avait ce petit truc on peut le faire
je tiens à préciser parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui m'ont posé la question on
peut le faire avec des lentilles donc
cette saison il y en a plusieurs qui
portaient des lentilles mais le soir on
enlève quand même les lentilles et il
faut vous enfin moi je me disais qu'il
fallait quand même voir un minimum un
truc bête mais sur une épreuve du SAL
dans les yeux avec les lentilles c'est
c'est impossible quoi ouais donc donc
voilà à ce momentlà je me suis j'ai j'ai
plus de frein donc je me dis bon sur un
coup de tête j'envoie j'envoie mon
courrier tu as fait tes photos en
maillot de bain du coup exactement parce
que j'ai cliqué sur le lien un jour moi
aussi et quand j'ai vu les photos qui
demandaient je fais en
flouais pour la blague tu aurais dû le
faire j'ai pas cru dès le début parce
que je me suis dit mais on est tellement
on sait qu'en moyenne c'est 40000
personnes ouais pourquoi moi 4000
inscrits av ouis mon année c'était 40000
après je pense que c'est la moyenne il y
a des années o c'est un peu plus un peu
moins et tu dis que voilà ils en
cherchent que 20 10 hommes donc 10 puis
en fait c'est tellement long ça a duré
je crois 7 mois entre le moment où j'ai
envoyé mon courrier et moment ils m'ont
dit ok fris tu pars quand il valide ta
présence ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
te libérer aussi un gros slot de temps
c'était possible c'était organisable
dans ta vie c'était ouais c'était
organisable ça on on le sait plus ou
moins de toute façon plus on avance dans
le casting plus ils nous disent quand
même que voilà il y a de grandes Chan
que sur cette période si tu pars il
faudra que tu sois libre à minima le
maximum donc 50 jours 50 jours c'est
énorme quand même 50 jours en fait il y
a 40 jours de de jeu mais après avec la
comment dire bah les billet les les vol
oui pour y aller parce qu'il y a un peu
plus de de journées de de voyage à
l'aller au retour le temps de se se
conditionner et puis le temps de
redescendre à la fin donc voilà
globalement c'était 50 jours mais
c'était 40 jours d'aventure la finale
elle est tourné en direct longtemps
après ton retour alors il y a pas de
règle selon les années c'est plus ou
moins long mais là le tournage c'était
l'été dernier donc ça s'est réellement
passé l'été dernier entre août et
septembre et puis la diffusion c'était
en février cette année jusqu'à juin donc
ouais il y a eu à peu près 6 mois
ouais quand tu as commencé l'aventure tu
t'es dit ton ton meilleur àout ce serait
quoi en fait c'est je misais vraiment
sur la la polyvalence parce que je me
disais que j'avais vraiment aucun souci
d'un point de vue social euh au niveau
sportif voilà je suis pas un sportif
professionnel mais euh mais voilà j'ai
une très bonne condition physique du
coup je me suis dit bon pas de souci de
ce côté-là non plus je serai pas par
parmi les plus faibles et je pense que
au début du jeu ça joue beaucoup
là-dessus parce qu'on te on te connaît
pas trop mais on te juge tout de suite
quoi et puis après il y a l'aspect il y
a l'aspect jeu et euh et donc la
stratégie je l'avais pas préparé mais je
m'étais dit que j'allais là-bas pour
jouer parce que je sais que justement
euh il y a beaucoup de gens qui vont
là-bas et qui sont très euh voilà je
vais je vais garder les les valeurs que
j'ai dans la vie je vais pas mentir et
pour eux c'est un peu une extension de
la vie colanta et je me suis dit que si
jamais je devais jouer là-dessus je
pourrais jouer là-dessus tu es tu es
joueur toi de base jeu de plateau jeu de
carte jeu de rôle oua ouais tout ouais
tout et puis euh je suis aussi assez
compétiteur c'est ok que même si on va
aller au bowlying ou oui c'est pas une
comp mais il faut que tu gagnes ouais
voilà voilà je vais prendre du plaisir à
jouer he certes en général ces profils
là sont des bons joueurs tu es bons
joueurs c'estàdire que si tu perds
dignement ou ok est-ce que tu t'étais
entraîné avant de partir genre avant de
partir genre les techniques de survie le
feu çavoir faire du feu la cuueillette
ce genre de chos tu avais fait un
entraînement je sais qu'il y en a qui le
font il y en a qui font pas du tout il y
en a qui qui le font vraiment beaucoup
ouais euh moi je l'ai pas du tout fait
je me suis dit que que je le ferai à
partir du moment où je serais sûr de
partir ok en gros je voulais pas
m'entraîner pour rien ouais je comprends
et vu que c la première année que je
m'inscrivais euh ben je m'étais dit bon
ben voilà si ça marche je vais
m'entraîner mais sinon pourquoi pourquoi
m'entraîner en fait et donc comme je te
disais le casting dure 7 mois et c'est
pas hyper intensif hein j'avais un
échange avec eux toutes les TR semaines
un mois et et voilà en fait comme il
disait que voilà je continue dans le
procès je me suis ok je continue et dès
que j'ai dès que j'aurais le GO je
m'entraîne et puis au final j'ai eu le
GO 3 semaines avant de partir donc pour
s'entraîner physiquement par rapport à
à aux épreuves type c'est c'est
compliqué et puis après je me suis
vraiment réveillé le jour J quand quand
quand on est arrivé limiteé à l'aéroport
qui nous ont dit ok on prend vos
téléphones dans 2 heures et vous les
récupérez que à votre tour et ben là
j'ai mis YouTube et j'ai mis ok comment
faire du feu comment tresser des
feuilles de palmiers comment faire des
nœuds et en réalité tout ce que j'ai vu
mais en last minute ça m'a tellement
aidé pendant laaventure ouais tu as fait
matrix tu as téléchargé de la donnée
ouais j'ai téléchargé de la donnée ça
m'a tellement tellement aidé ta femme
elle a elle était heureuse pour toi ou
elle a appréendé ton départ parce que
c'est un peu elle qui te dit vas-y
inscris-toi qu' te pousse et après elle
te voit partir pour potentiellement de
mois quoi ouais on y croyait pas
vraiment à chaque fois que je lui disais
bon ben voilà j'ai eu un co ça a l'air
de fonctionner on avance on avance en
fait on était vraiment resté terre à
terre début jusqu'à la fin parce que moi
je je suis comme ça dans la vie tant que
c'est pas acté euh voilà je vais
pasfaronner on l'a dit à personne il y
avait vraiment que ma femme qui savait
que j'étais dans ce process là et en fin
de compte euh quand on enfin quand on
m'a dit que je partais je m' dit ok mais
je ne savais pas combien de temps et tu
as encore cette possibilité de pouvoir
sortir très vite du jeu donc tu as
encore cette appréhension c'était quand
même une victoire de se dire voilà tu es
pris pour le jeu et après tu commences à
avoir des nouveaux stress qui se
déclenche tu vois est-ce que comment je
vais faire ça se trouve jeire non mais
la hantiste de tous les tous les
candidats tu vas tu fais tu fais 24
heures je pars et puis voilà je lui dis
jusqu'à à peu près telle ou telle date
si je viens pas c'est que voilà j'ai
passé la moitié du jeu et du coup bah
c'est cool et et là ça devient sérieux
mais mais ouai elle a eu de
l'appréhension quand même tu as beaucoup
marqué les esprits en tout cas les
personnes avec qui j'ai pu parler de toi
comme étant un des plus grands voire le
plus grand stratège qu' eu dans dans
conona tu t'es t'es dit que la stratégie
tu la verrais au au Cap par cas mais
est-ce que tu pensais qu'elle serait
aussi présente voire plus importante que
le côté sportif par exemple en je p P
vraiment que ma ma polyvalence a fait
que je sois allé aussi loin parce que
d'un point de vue social je me suis très
bien entendu avec tout le monde sur tout
mon jeu j'ai eu un seul vote contre moi
ouais étaé volontaire sur le camp et
voilà et puis et puis d'un point de vue
sportif j'ai j'ai gagné pas mal
d'épreuves j'ai été déc dans pas mal
d'épreuves en équipe tout ça donc je
pense que voilà c'est c'est un tout mais
c'est vrai que l'aspect stratégique je
l'avais
pas autant anticipé c'est sur sur sur le
début de l'aventure quand j'ai commencé
à être en danger o je me suis je suis
dis ok faut que tu tentes ça et quand
j'ai tenté mon premier bluff et que ça a
marché je me suis dit mais en fait c'est
trop puissant ce truc ou c'est une arme
en fait tellement puissante et en fait
tout le monde l'a à disposition mais
très peu de gens décident de l'utiliser
vraiment pour beaucoup de participants
c'est vraiment un rêve de participer à
colant donc il voit vraiment ça comme un
peu une extension de la vie et du coup
ils ont ils ont peur ils veulent plus
assurer les choses en faisant attention
voilà peut-être l'image aussi et c'est
vrai que ce qui est compli c'est que tu
joues avec des gens ou donc tu tu mens
ok tu mens dans le cadre du jeu mais tu
mens réellement à des gens que tu viens
juste de connaître donc tu tu sais pas
après comment ils peuvent prendre les
choses en une fois une fois sorti du jeu
en fait faut se dire qu'il ment à des
joueurs c'est exactement ça et moi c'est
exactement le le mindset que j'avais et
je pense que c'est ce qui m'a permis
d'aller aussi loin et de et de prendre
autant de plaisir dans le jeu parce que
moi j'ai moi j'ai vraiment pris du j'ai
pris mon pied moi à mentir à faire à
mettre ses stratégies en place à à à
jouer quoi tout simplement oui on entend
beaucoup dans ce genre d'émission en
tout cas dans colanta moi j'ai des
valeurs moi j'ai des mais effectivement
si tu fais une partie de loup-garouou un
jeu de rôle avec quelqu'un ça va
commencer à devenir ridicule donc
peut-être probablement des personnes qui
arrivent pas à oublier le fait que ce
soit une émission et qu'on va les voir
jouer qu'il y a une confusion entre qui
ils sont in game et quis sont dans la
vraie vie quoi toi tu t'es dit je m'en
[__] mer je je je veux jouer quoi en
fait je je me suis dit que je m'en
foutais mais au-delà de ça cette
confusion le le public qui qui regarde
là aussi a fait cette confusion c'est
que et je pense que ça vient du public
justement le fait que quand tu es STR
quand tu es stratège tu tu es tout de
suite mal vu B c'est c'est ça c'est
c'est marrant parce que la version
américaine de de colanta donc Survivor
eux c'est tout à fait le contraire ils
sont à fond dans la strat et à la limite
quand il y a pas de strat bah tu jartes
quoi tu es c'éit pas intéressant ou
ouais quand il y a eu le changement
d'équipe que tu as menti pour la
première fois je crois ouis ouo dans ta
tête à ce momentl cétait je veux bien
que tu racontes ouais ou ouais en fait
donc je j'étais chez les jaunes au
départ et euh et on on avait fait une
une une épreuve où finalement le perden
sortait et puis à ce moment-là on se
retrouve je crois neuf jaunes et euh et
si rougge et je pense que la la prod
avait prévu ce ce coup là et c'était dit
non mais si si se passe ce cas de figure
là il faut qu'on fasse quelque chose bah
oui parce que sinon c'est c'est trop
téléphoné quoi pour la suite du jeu
c'est c'est trop facile et et donc voilà
dispatch des équipes les équipes se
refont complètement parce que à ce
moment-là dans le jeu je me sentais mais
tellement bien j'étais dit mais limite
ça devient trop facile et en fait quand
il se passe ça euh le destin en tout cas
le jeu comment il a été tourné a a fait
les choses c'est-à-dire la la nouvelle
enfin les deux nouvelles équipes et ben
ça a été hyper bien par dispatché ok
donc moi je faisais partie des nouveaux
rouges et ben on était quand même en
minorité les les AX jaunes parce qu'on
avait des AX jaunes qui avaient un peu
vifurqué bah j'avais pas trop le choix
soit soit je tentais un premier mensonge
pour essayer de me libérer euh soit je
voilà en gros soit je subissais mon
aventure quoi et donc je me souviens je
vais je vais mentir à à Esteban et je
lui dis droit dans le droit dans les
yeux en lui serrant la main et je me dis
à ce moment-là parce que je sais qu' qui
va se passer ce moment-là où je vais
devoir lui mentir dans les yeux et il
faudra pas que j'ai le regard fuyant il
faudra pas que que ça se voit donc c'est
un vrai travail d'acteur quoi je je suis
pas un acteur mais en fait ça m'a fait
rire ça m fa ton mensonge c'est ça il
faut le et donc je lui mentais mais je
je continue à le regarder dans les yeux
je t'inquiète pas t'inquiète C ban non
fait ça je lui s à la main et tout et
puis en fait en donc sur le coup je me
sentais hyper mal et puis et puis
c'était difficile à faire justement de
mentir de en regardant droit dans les
yeux tout ça et puis au final quand ça
s'est passé et que et que ça a
fonctionné je me suis dit mais c'est
trop puissant ce truc oui c'est juste
trop fort et et je me suis ben je je
vais continuer la aventure en en jouant
tout simplement être bon stratège aussi
c'est savoir mettre des stratégies en
place et faire en sorte qu'elles aillent
au bout ou pour faire en sorte que que
ça aille au bout tu es obligé de mentir
parce que tu tu ne peux pas dire toute
la vérité à tout le monde autrement bah
et puis c'est un jeu de Highlander il en
restera qu'un donc à un moment donné il
y a des alliances qui doivent sauter il
y a des choses comme ça exactement mais
faut pas oublier que c'est un jeu où on
nous demande de voter entre nous tu sais
aussi que ton vote tout seul il va pas
servir à grandchose donc il faut que tu
amènes des gens avec toi si tu amènes
des gens avec toi pour pour voter au
mérite B en fait ça reste une une
stratégie et en fait c'est ça c'est ça
qu'il faut garder en tête c'est que
c'est que peu importe ce que tu fait
finalement euh il y a une stratégie
derrière toi tu ça ça t'a impacté les
les commentaires négatifs tu t'y
attendais toi en rentrant d'avoir des
commentaires négatifs sur les réseaux ou
des gens comme ça qui trop prochent des
choses par rapport à mon aventure comme
je l'ai vécu je pensais pas sincèrement
je me suis dit bah non euh après moi
j'ai j'ai vécu mon aventure comme comme
bon me semblait j'ai adoré la vie comme
ça donc malgré les les les commentaires
que j'ai pu avoir je je ne regrette rien
du tout mais c'est vrai que j'ai été
surpris par la la puissance de de
certains commentaires virulents enfin
faut être motivé quand même dans dans
cette démarche de haine de de dire parce
que il y a il y a la la personne qui est
à fond dans le jeu ok ouais il se passe
ça OK et dire [__] mais il est con
d'avoir fait ça lui ok c'est une chose
mais là dire voilà lui il est con ok je
vais aller chercher son insta
je va je vais je vais lui écrire ok tu
es un con ah ouais tu recevais des
messages directement sur tes réseau
c'était pas tu vois moi là j'étais
encore dans genre la bulle Twitter tu
tapais hasht colant est que tu pis
Twitter j'adore ça me fait rire ça me
fait rire mais mais auelà de ça tu des
personnes qui viennent t'écrire
personnellement qui qui qui font la
démarche de de venir t'écrire en fait ça
je trouve ça je trouve ça incroyable tu
as pris du temps pour leur répondre au
départ comme s'il y avait un un combat
ou assez vite tu as compris que en vrai
c'est eux même qui s'est inventé un
combat et qui t'avait pas perçu qui tu
étais et qui avait rien à non en fait je
trouve globalement je trouve ça triste
justement que les gens n'ai pas perçu le
le la personne derrière le le joueur
ouais eu après non je je me suis pas
amusé à à aller réponde je me suis dit
que c'était pas la chose à faire et puis
quand je te parle de de message négatif
ça représente quoi peut-être 2 % sur sur
les les 100 % de messages positifs que
j'ai euou on le sait qu'il peuvent
marquer parfois au f rouge quand tu un
qui m' qui m'a vraiment qui m'a secoué
qui m'a énervé et là je me suis je vais
je vais répondre je vais je vais
l'afficher ou je vais faire quelque
chose mais mais j'ai rien fait ouais il
faut supprimer très vite dans ces cas-là
pour pas être tenté de lui répondre quoi
en fait c'est c'est juste la démarche
que je trouve vraiment enfin je trouve
ça triste au final ça m'a énervé ça m'a
fait monter en tension mais je me suis
dit au final mais le mec il enfin c'est
c'est triste quoi de d'écrire un message
comme ça et donc le le gars m'écrit donc
mon père est décédé quand j'avais 20 ans
et il m'écrit juste va rejoindre ton
père
terrifiant ou tu PES tes mots quoi enfin
je sais pas tu vois c'est c'est un jeu
ok tu m'apprécies pas il y a pas de
souci c'est pas grave mais reste
tranquille qui c'est horrible et je
comprends la montée en pression on peut
que la comprendre ce qui est injuste
dans les émotion que ça t'a fait
ressentir parce que cette phrase elle
est obsène quoi tu vois le moment où il
l'écrit lui il s'amuse le moment où il
appuyé sur Entrée il oublie presque
qu'il a envoyé ça et c'est des bombes à
retardement dans le temps et toi tu vas
recevoir ça comme s'il était en face de
toi qui venait de le prononcer alors que
lui vraiment tu vois c'est vraiment très
gratuit quoi donc ben bravo d'avoir
réussi à gérer ces émotions là parce que
ça doit pas être si simple n'empêche non
mais franchement à part celui-là après
tous les autres je m'en fiche on sait on
sait quand même un minimum qu'on va être
B mis en avant ouais c'est un peu
dangereux parce que on se dit en
entrant on sait qu'on va potentiellement
avoir une vague de quelque chose ouais
et on ne sait pas quoi je l'ai ressenti
auprès certains candidats euh dans leur
manière d'être tout au long du jeu qui
anticipaient peut-être euh justement les
réseaux tout ça ou ok je comprends et en
fait en fait c'est dommage c'est dommage
parce que justement quand on rentre dans
une aventure comme ça je pense qu'il
faut être vraiment sans filtre à fond
dans ce dans ce jeu en fait ils avaient
une stratégie mais une stratégie de
l'après et de leur vie sociale ou
professionnel que la stratégie du jeu
quoi c'est ça et ok bah c'est bien c'est
un c'est un parti prix mais je trouve
que ça ça dénature un peu le le jeu quoi
et puis toi tu l'as vécu pleinement pas
comme une émission de télé en fait non
non non c'est pour ça que des fois je me
suis j'ai j'ai vraiment dit ça vraiment
sans filtre quoi et pas tout m dit non
mais c'est c'est trop fort mais c'est
c'est marrant de te voir comme ça parce
qu'il m' ils m'ont reconnu tout de suite
et et je suis content de me dire voilà
j'étais dedans et j'étais moi en fait et
et ceux qui me connaissent ils me
reconnaissent et puis sorte de
loup-garou géant quand on joue au
loupgarou on se pose pas la question de
il m' menti il disait qu'il était
villageois quoi exactement et quand on
est loup-garou des fois on sacrifie
l'autre loupgarou c'est ça tu as
sacrifié quelqu'un tu as sacrifié
Nicolas du coup c'est ça alors ça
c'était le le grand débat on il y en a
qui disent que tu as trahi Nicolas et
d'autres qui disent que c'était plutôt
malin il y avait eu la promesse de si je
vais en finale je t'emmène avec moi le
moment où tu où tu lui dis ça c'est
sincère h il me semble mais c'est pas
lui qui t'a emmené en finale non en fait
ce ce qu'il faut savoir et je pense que
c'est là où on le voit pas peut-êre pas
bien au niveau de l'émission parce que
bah il y a le montage tout ça mais donc
on était quatre quatre alliés on s'est
dit qu'on s'emmener le plus loin
possible et après à partir de
l'orientation ben
viennent que pour parce qu'il y a plus
de a plus de strat c'est la B et en fin
de compte le dernier conseil avant avant
l'orientation je perds mon pote de
l'aventure qui est Quentin et à ce
moment-là donc il nous reste enfin il
reste que Nicolas et moi de notre de
notre alliance de quatre et face à de
filles et donc pour moi à ce moment-là
c'est logique je lui dis de manière
vraiment transparente et et sans
arrière-pensé je lui dis bah écoute on
est plus que deux dans dans l'alliance
si je gagne les potau Je te choisis
parce que c'est logique sans avoir pensé
en fait à la à la finale et à
l'éventuelle victoire à ce momentlà et
lui il me répond tout de suite merci
mais moi je peux pas dire pareil il faut
que je réfléchisse et donc je me suis
dit attends faut qu'il réfléchisse mais
ça veut dire que lui il réfléchit en
fait directement à la à la victoire et
tout donc c'est très intelligent c'est
bien il pas le nord quoi de jours se
passe parce qu'il y a la il y a
l'orientation et donc le jour des femes
poteau et 2h avant avant avant l'épreuve
des poteau il me dit ok Fred bah j'ai
réfléchi et si si c'est si c'est moi qui
gagne Je te choisis aussi et donc bah
dans ce cas-là je je me suis dit bon ben
c'est c'est cool quoi on se choisit tous
les tous les deux puis on est en finale
c'est c'est trop bien si l'un nous deux
gagne arrive les poteau et là en fait je
monte sur les poteau et je me dis mais
c'est trop facile comme
épreuve en fait je me sens très trs
allaise très vite et je me dis mais je
vais la gagner C cette épreuve et à ce
moment-là je me dis mais en fait ok il y
a la finale et donc la finale ben les
gens votent et là je suis en train de me
faire le le bah la finale tout
simplement et je me dis qui va voter
pour moi euh qui va voter pour Nico et
je me dis je vais avoir qu'une seule
voix celle de Quentin et à ce moment-là
je me dis mais en fait non je peux pas
oui parce que c'est tous les anciens
aventuriers qui c'est c'est juste pour
ceux qui nous écoutent ou qui nous
regardent et qui connaissent bien les
règles c'est tous les anciens
aventuriers de l'aventure qui vont
choisir par les voilà par les deux
dernières personnes donc comme toi tu
connais tout le monde tu peux projeter
un peu qui va VO exactement exactement
il y a il y a il y a le côté il y a le
côté social bien sûr donc ceux qui
étaient proches plus proche de Nico ou
ou moi et puis après il y a le jeu et en
fin de compte quasiment toutes les
personnes qu'on a sorti c'était des
stratégies qu'on avait mis en place
ensemble mais moi je m'étais pas du tout
caché ouais moi j'étais
vraiment assumé moi j'ai fait si parce
que voilà je je voulais sortir à ce
moment-là et à chaque fois que
j'expliqué aux gens en plus même moi qui
suis fair playay si je me retrouve à
leur place je ne voterai pas pour le
gars qui m'a sorti il y a eu un conseil
euh je sais pas quelques jours avant ou
où Nicolas avait gagné une immunité donc
c'était un peu son conseil et donc Denis
demandait un peu à tous les tous les
candidats ce qu'il pensait de de Nico et
Nico il avait les ovations de de tout le
monde quoi gr Dang JAMA
je me suis dit je je je ne peux pas
gagner contre lui pour la première fois
du jeu je commence à à à stresser je
stressais parce que je me suis dit je
peux pas prendre cette décision mais je
lui ai dit que j'allais la prendre et
donc je me dis à ce moment-là justement
ben je vais devoir bah lui dire quoi
tout simplement que que je peux pas le
prendre et en même temps je suis
tellement content d'avoir eu cette ce
moment de lucidité parce que ce qu'on ce
qu'on ce qu'on voit pas à la télé c'est
que l'aspect survie justement le fait
qu'on mange très peu ça nous impacte
physiquement mais mentalement aussi
avoir l'esprit clair tout le temps c'est
pas facile avoir cette lucidité quand on
est très fatigué quand on pense qu'à
qu'à manger euh c'est pour ça que des
fois on voit des des coups stratégies
mais on se dit mais il a pas vu venir
celle-là bah non il a pas vu venir il
est trop fatigué pas normalement quand
pas normal de nutriment et de sommeil
exactement tu es tu es tout le temps
sous tension tu vas entendre un mot de
traverse ça va te faire monter et donc
c'est hyper difficile de garder cette
lucidité et donc je suis très content à
ce moment-là de de me dire tu fais 40 j
d'aventure c'est un jeu on le sait
depuis le début à la fin il n restera
qu'un si tu gagnes les poteaux il te
reste une action dans le jeu pour
éventuellement gagner tu peux pas
prendre cette mauvaise décision et au
moment où je gagne je me dis ben c'est
décidé je peux pas le choisir B oui non
mais je trouvé que c'était bien que tu
puisses nous dire ce qui s'est passé
dans ta tête à ce moment-l et cetera et
ce que tu as ressenti et le fait que tu
sois le grand gagnant de l'émission
montre que c'était encore une fois le
bon choix à faire tout à fait parce que
on pourra avoir une lecture très très
différente de tous tes choix si tu avais
pas été le gagnant ultime tu vois mais
là a priori chaque action était bonne et
était nécessaire au sens propre du terme
quoi on parle beaucoup de ta stratégie
là aujourd'hui on en parlait beaucoup en
positif ou en négatif je trouve que ça
met un petit peu de côté quand même
l'aspect sportif où tu as été tu as été
brillant tu com comment tu l'as vécu
tout ça dès la sortie du jeu la toute
fin on m'a tout de suite cataloguer
comme étant grand stratège et puis h un
stratège qui gagne l'émission ouais mais
on oublie
que que justement bah il y a eu ces
victoires en individuel qui qui ont été
décisives j'ai gagné la dernière imunité
qui m'a permis
d'arriver comment dire en en finale à à
l'orientation puis après j'ai gagné les
poteau et puis parce que si tu avais pas
eu cette immunité tu aurais peut-être pu
sauter ce soir-l je pense je pense et je
pense que ça jouit entre Quentin et moi
justement ce jour-l donc donc voilà j'ai
j'ai j'ai eu des victoires décisives sur
la première partie en équipe je pense
avoir été quand même assez assez M ur
dans dans dans les différentes épreuves
mais c'est vrai que le public garde
vraiment la dernière image qu'on va
laisser et donc la dernière image
c'était ce cou stratégique ok si c'est
comme ça qu'ils veulent le voir ben toi
tu es fier de toi moi je suis très fier
de moi de aussi bien de de la sur
l'aspect sportif que sur l'aspect strat
et tu tu tu faisais d'autres sports à
côté avant est-ce que tu as déjà fait
par exemple je sais pas du running des
marathons des en fait j'ai fait 10 ans
d'arts martiaux j'ai fait j'ai fait du
kung fu du wendo de la box thaïlandaise
du MMA et à chaque fois en compétition
amateur du coup ma question elle était
pas anodine ce que je voulais savoir
c'est est-ce que en rentrant donc tu
prends l'avion tu rentres on ne sait pas
encore si tu es l'ultime vainqueur ou
pas mais est-ce que déjà d'avoir fait
toute l'aventure en entier tuéprouvve la
même chose que quand tu peux gagner une
médaille ou un tournoi en sport ouais
c'est c'est une c'est une fierté et et
je crois que le moment où je l'ai
vraiment plus se ressenti c'était pas
forcément dans l'avion au au moment du
retour mais c'était plus au moment où où
j'arrive à enfoncer ce poignard aussi à
l'orientation ouais et que tu sais que
tu vas aller à la dernière épreuve
doncas que tu as fait tout le jeu ouais
donc pour moi c'était c'était un cap
très très très symbolique ouais tu vas
pour jouer une aventure et aujourd'hui
combien
d'aventuriers me me disent voilà j'aait
trop aimé faire les poteau le gagner ou
pas mais le faire et donc le faire en
fait faut déjà imaginer tout ce qu'il
faut pour arriver jusqu'à cette épreuve
faut la mériter cette épreuve cette
fierté là je l'ai ressenti à ce
moment-là on arrive du coup oui à la
fameuse épreuve des poteau tu te sens
comment avant l'épreuve physiquement
mentalement alors avant l'épreuve je me
sens pas pas au top parce que la
veille ouais je me suis blessé donc tous
les soirs on se réveille 1 et une fois
dans la nuit parce qu'on dort pas bien
et et donc à ce moment-là je me lève je
me dis bon je vais je vais jeter un œil
au feu et puis en fin de compte je
marche sur sur comment dire une racine
qui était tranchante et je m'écorche
vraiment un gros morceau de chair et là
je me dit mais comment est-ce possible
c'est pilpoil l'endroit en plus où on
s'appuie sur les poteaux quoi c'était
sur le côté du pied là mais donc dans la
nuit je me suis dit mais non pas la pas
la veille des poteau c'est pas possible
je je me blesse pas de de toute
l'aventure et la veille des poteau et
donc forcément le reste de la nuit je
fais que de cogiter donc j'ai très peu
dormi on arrive sur l'épreuve donc on
doit marcher d'abord se mettre dans
l'eau avant de monter donc déjà mettre
dans l'eau l'eau salée sur la pie ça ça
réveille et puis après se mettre sur le
poteau j'étais pas j'étais pas serein du
tout quoi j'étais très fatigué du fait
de pas avoir dormi j'ai dû mordre les
points tout au long de de de l'épreuve
pour rester éveillé et et comment dire
concentré à fond parce que en fait le
moindre coup de vent il y avait beaucoup
de vent jourl pouvait nous déstabiliser
et si on n pas à chaque fois au Zaga à
100 % sur toute toutes l'épreuve c'est
compliqué et puis une chose qui m'a
beaucoup aidé aussi c'est que cette
journée-là c'était une grosse symbolique
parce que la la date de l'épreuve des
poteau c'était l'anniversaire du décès
de mon père comme tous les matins il y
avait l'unou qui allait faire un petit
point sur un arbre pour marquer le
nombre de jours et ben j'ai mis j'ai mis
ce ce dernier petit point des 40 jours
sur la date et je me suis dit ok bon
est-ce que ça va me porter chance
qu'est-ce que ça va et au final je me
suis beaucoup appuyé dessus et je pense
que ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup ouis ouais
je t'avais entendu dire que à un moment
donné tu as tu as limite cru voir ton
père pendant que tu étais sur les poteau
ouais c'est c'est très bizarre parce que
je crois pas forcément tout ça et et
donc je m'étais dit bon allez je je fixe
un point au loin et après je je pense
que c'est un un mélange de tout parce
que justement il y avait il y avait ça
il y avait dans mon esprit cette date
qui était hyper symbolique je me suis
dit je je que je voulais pas perdre non
plus sur cette date là je voulais et je
m'étais dit en plus que que que si je
gagnais à ce moment-là ça pourrait
donner un côté positif à cette date qui
qui est très très très triste pour moi
et puis vu que j'étais très fatigué
aussi je me demande si au bout d'un
moment tu sais tu tu tu te mets
pas halluciner ouais parce que je me
mordais vraiment fort pour pour voilà
pour me réveiller exactement et et donc
par moment je me disais au loin mais
c'est marrant on dirait une silhouette
et on dirait mon père et je pense que
c'est un mélange de tout ça toutes ces
émotion et puis on est tellement encore
une fois poussé à bout manque de
nourriture tout ça donc je pense que
tout ce mélange fait que on peut voir
tout ce que tout ce qu'on tout ce qu'on
imagine en fin de compte que
l'explication soit rationnelle ou
irrationnel ça t'a donné de la force à
ce ça donné de la force clairement tu
l'as vraiment accompagné ton père si je
dis pas de bêtis tuas tu as même
embrassé le l'habit du moine bouddhiste
pour aller au bout avec lui donc c'est
pas rien quand même c'était a 13 ans
c'est çaoua ouais c'était il y a 13 ans
j'avais j'avais 20 ans et en fait à ce
moment-là à 20 ans on est on est tout
juste majeur et à 20 temps perdre son
père de qui on était très proche c'est
c'est vraiment c'est la fin du monde
j'ai j'ai mis énormément de temps à me
remettre et puis et puis en plus
quasiment le lendemain on me dit ma mère
me dit est-ce que tu veux tu veux faire
ça pour ton père devenir moine pendant
pendant le temps des obsèques pour
accompagner en fait cette transition
entre guillemets et en fait moi il y
avait même pas de de question quoi
c'était oui je le fais Mo Bou ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire se raser le le
crâne les sourcils
aller au temple prier et en fin de
compte moi je savais pas ce que c'était
d'aller au temple et prier et moi qui
croyais pas en grandchose qui crois pas
en grand-chose de manière générale mais
si je suis bouddhiste parce que mes
parents le sontiliation voilà exactement
et et en fin de compte il y a le je sais
pas comment on peut l'appeler le le plus
ancien des des moines qui m'explique à
ce moment-là quand il me voit en train
de complètement effondré en fait au
temple il me dit c'est pas bien ce que
tu fais euh parce que pleurer ça va pas
aider ton père à partir c'est de
l'énergie négative c'est exactement ça
et en fait euh pour ceux qui croivent ou
pas qui croit ou pas euh au au au au
monde de l'au-delà tout ça c'est que
admettons qu'on a une âme en suspens et
si cette âme est trop attachée euh à ce
qui se passe encore ici elle va pas
pouvoir aller vivre enfin continuer sa
vie ailleurs et et donc ces ces émotions
négatives peuvent justement euh empêcher
euh euh là je vais donner une image mais
si mon père il voit que tout le monde
est trop triste là il va peut-être
vouloir rester là pour pour nous nous
consoler ou quoi que ce soit et donc à
ce moment-là ce moine me donne une image
extrêmement forte extrêmement puissante
et il me dit il me dit non tu dois avoir
que des pensées positive tu ne dois pas
pleurer pour pour ton père et ce jusqu'à
jusqu'au jour de l'enterrement tout ça
quand il me dit ça je je le j'ai du mal
à le digérer encore je continue à à à
être complètement effondré pendant de 3
jours J et puis finalement j'ai eu le
temps de de de comment dire de de
digérer et puis à ce moment-là il s'est
passé quelque chose de très bizarre
c'est que en fait j'essayais d'avoir il
essaie de me donner des conseils me dit
essaie de de penser qu'au moment de
bonheur avec ton père des souvenirs tout
bêtes où vous avez pu rire ensemble
passer des bons moments et et en fait
c'est comme si mon mon cerveau se
mettait en en mode défense et que
voulait pas accéder à ces à ses
souvenirsir là d'accord pour peut-être
pas me faire du mal et moi je devais
accéder à ces souvenirs pour pas pour
pas fondre et euh et jusqu'à aujourd'hui
j'ai encore du mal en fait à quand quand
j'essaie de d'avoir des des souvenirs
très positifs de mon père j'ai encore du
mal en fait c'est un peu muré quoi ouais
c'est c'est c'est très particulier j'ai
j'ai deux trois images mais mais j'ai
pas 20 ans d'images ouis alors que je
devrais avoir 20 ans d'image et eu et au
final on arrive le le jour de
l'enterrement et j'arrive à faire le
nécessaire malgré toute la famille mes
proches ma mère mes frères et sœurs qui
qui étaient complètement en larme à
rester
limite stoïque limite avoir le le
sourire en coin en me disant voilà papa
vraiment je vais je vais je vais je vais
t'accompagner je vais faire je vais
faire ce qu'il faut pour pour que ça
marche et avoir B du coup les deux trois
mini souvenirs que j'ai réussi à à
capter vraiment en tête toute la journée
quoi dans dans la vie d'un homme une
épreuve comme ça notamment à 20 ans ça
ça impacte très profondément ouais puis
nous ça nous donne une clé aussi pour
bien comprendre en quoi cette date
identique
en haut du poteau a de l'importance tu
vois parce que c'est c'est pas c'est pas
que le départ de ton papa c'est tout ce
que ça englobe aussi d'ailleurs ton père
était apparu un autre moment durant
l'émission il me semble tu avais rêvé de
lui pas quelque chose de commun pour toi
de rêver de lui quoi ouais en fait dans
dans la culture asiatique on dit que
quand quand on ne rêve pas d'un proche
qui est décédé c'est que ce proche ne
pense plus à vous et c'est très très
très bizarre mais donc là là ça là ça a
fait 14 ans que mon père est est parti
et et en 14 ans j'ai dû rêver 5 fois de
mon père donc c'est hyper et donc quand
ça arrive ça impacte énormément et en
fin de compte la veille de l'épreuve
d'immunité qui m'emmèna au à
l'orientation j'ai rêvé de lui et bom tu
gagnes derrière et bom je gagne derrière
oui non non mais c'est beau encore une
fois on parle de de croyance spirituel
ou pas mais l'assemblage des choses est
est assez rigolo pour montrer encore une
fois à quel point ouais tout ça fait
sens quand quand tu es en haut des
poteaux tu es resté combien de temps sur
les poteau euh 1h30 1h30 parce qu' au
bout d' 1h30 on a enlevé la deuxième
clavette en fait c'est poteau il y a
trois clavettes faire en sorte que la
surface se réduise ouais et à la
deuxième les deux autres sont sont
tombés ok donc on a même pas eu
l'opportunité d'aller jusqu'au jusqu'au
bout et la ma dernière question c'est du
coup tu as vécu un truc que je rangerai
dans la catégorie des jeux ultimes quand
même tu vois c'est on vit des émotions
très fortes sur les jeux de société mais
on met pas sa santé à l'épreuve et on
repousse pas tout aussi loin ça peut
marcher que dans le cadre comme ça d'une
émission est-ce que tu as envie de
refaire un autre jeu télévisé une autre
émission télévisée comme ça ou c'est un
truc ça t'a pas trop traversé l'esprit
euh je suis joueur donc en fait s'il y a
un jeu qui
m'intéresse j'irai pour le jeu pour le
plaisir et puis pour l'aspect sportif
aussi tu tu tu l'as bien souligné ce qui
ce qui a été vraiment incroyable dans
dans cette expérience de Colona c'est
c'est le fait que
encore une fois on est tout le temps
poussé à bout on a tout le temps faim on
dort pas beaucoup donc tout est décuplé
le fait qu'on soit coupé du monde aussi
et combien de fois on a vécu des hauts
et des bas entre le moment où on perd
une épreuve entre le moment o on gagne
une épreuve on a l'impression que que
notre monde se résume à ça mais c'est
tellement puissant et et et je dirais
même que rarement j'ai j'ai vécu des des
des situations aussi aussi intenses que
ce soit dans le positif comme dans le
négatif pendant cette aventure et voilà
c'est ce qui a rendu les l'expérience
unique donc même à refaire le le Colona
je le referai parce que je suis un
joueur et et ça sera un peu remett
remettre ma ceinture sur la table donc
je le ferai ben merci beaucoup merci à
toi Fabien merci à Fred pour sa
générosité vous pouvez aussi retrouver
les épisodes des intervatable parfois en
version longue sur le Podcast je vous
mets le lien dans la description à très
bientôt Ciao